Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright is not
allowed to violate the SCP Foundation dress
code, nor encourage others to do so, even
on “Casual Fridays.”
A note appended to this rule reads, “No
matter how many times you say please, Dr.
Bright, we won't put any of the hats you've
been asking about into the dress code.”
And the list of hats that
Dr. Bright has facetiously
requested has been nothing short of impressive,
including a freakishly tall, white “Doug
Dimmadome”-esque cowboy hat, and a novelty
propellor hat with actual, functioning helicopter
propellors.
A number of other hats he’s suggested - simple,
non-anomalous baseball caps with humorous
slogans printed on them - have been deemed
to be HR violations.
Sorry, Jack.